You don't necessarily need to have a
Computer Science degree to be successful
as a Ruby developer.
I went to art school, which doesn't seem
to have anything to do with code, but
it was still an extremely valuable
set of experiences that I was able to
bring with me.
For example, one of the most important
parts of art school is critique,
where we give each other
feedback on our work.
Through this process, I learned how
to accept and internalize criticism
in a way that helps me work
well with others on a team.
Think about some of your own experiences
that you're bringing with you into this
nano degree program.
Whether you're coming from sales,
have worked for a family business, or
are still a student,
everyone comes to code with some sort
of transferable skill or knowledge.
Take a moment to reflect on some
of your own transferable skills.